hello everybody my name is hello
everybody we are selling pajama pants
and posters with the art that workout
marks what I'm wearing them can I scream
no you haven't even had dinner yet
no mr. Sandman bring me a dream
[Music]
[Applause]
Lucy hey Lucy
hey come on say hi to everybody yeah say
hi hey yo Josie are you going buddy are
you doing
[Music]
do you think I'm pretty
how about now
[Applause]
[Music]
oh bus
this is Optimus Prime we must defend
Michael Bay whatever the cost
he makes us money its way to do
I'm in your light
beautiful I got out on camera I got some
fans with me here
[Applause]
[Music]
do you wanna build a snowman
you might wanna run away